dieses Video wird Barilla nicht gefallen
wir machen Spaghetti und Pesto in unter
30 Minuten selbst für die Nudeln
brauchen wir mehl Eier bisschen Olivenöl
fürs Pesto Basilikum Parmesan Knoblauch
Pinienkerne und auch ein bisschen
Olivenöl legen wir los mit dem Teig 200
g Mehl machen uns eine kleine Kuhle in
der Mitte und die schlagen wir unsere
Eier zack 100 g Mehl ein Ei die Eier
verquillen und nach und nach das Mehl
einer Arbeit wenn es mit der Gabel nicht
mehr weiter geht mit den Händen zu einer
glatten Masse verkneten unser Teig so
aussieht nehmen wir uns ein bisschen
Klarsichtfolie wickeln ihn ein und
lassen einfach 10 Minuten ruhen so dass
das Mehl die Feuchtigkeit aufnimmt jetzt
stellen wir die größte Stufe ein und
arbeiten uns langsam fort
Baguette Aufsatz drauf abgeht die Post
und fertig sind unsere Spaghetti und die
geben Sie direkt in gesalzenes Wasser
jetzt machen schnelles Pesto Basilikum
Knoblauchzehe Olivenöl ein bisschen Salz
und pürieren in den Kerne dazu leicht
zerstoßen
Parmesan dazu unterheben und fertig ist
unser Pesto die Spaghetti sind fertig
und wir geben unser Pesto dazu bisschen
Nudelwasser probieren wir
[Musik]